Ось такий пучок - свіжачок - результат інновації. Ця виробнича лінія миє, сушить, пакує зелень,
аби вона була одразу готова до вжитку. Підприємство придбало цю лінію в кредит,
який отримало за програмою Європейського інвестиційного фонду.
Отримати кредит на придбання такої лінії в банку,
що не працює з європейськими програмами, складно.
Отримати можна, але ціна питання буде геть іншою. Від 20% до 22% річних, що для нас дуже дорого.
Частину суми - 70 тисяч євро - у гривневому еквівалентіпідприємство отримало на 3 роки.
Заставою стала, власне, сама виробнича лінія. Програма Європейського інвестиційного фонду
діє з минулого року і кредитує малі та середні підприємства під 15-17% річних.
Ці кращі умови можливі через те, що ризики гарантування кредитів фонд поділив з банком – партнером в Україні.
У випадку збитків до 50% будуть покриті нашими партнерами. І це надає набагатобільше впевненості
при прийнятті рішень. І тому компанія або проект, який ми раніше може і не могли фінансувати,
або фінансувати в достатньому об’ємі, зараз стає можливим.
Приблизно 25 мільйонів євро, які передбачені програмою гарантування кредитів, ProCreditбанк
за піврокувже видав. Ці гроші строком на 3 або 5 років отримали 57 малих та середніх підприємств,
здебільшого в аграрному секторі. Поки проблем з поверненням відсотків не виникало.
Завдяки прокредитованій інновації "Свіжа зелень" змогла збільшити обсяг виробництва на 30%.
І розраховує повернути кредит приблизно за 2 роки. Мета європейських кредитних програм,
які реалізуються в Україні – сприяти розвитку малого і середнього бізнесу. Загальна сума
програми гарантування кредитів Європейського інвестфонду – 50 мільйонів євро.